hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round seven of the
2018 bill chest first of all like I said
I will show all three games from round
seven as all of them were were excellent
it's a shocking Dharma media versus
David navara now this game is a really
really crazy navara really goes for for
a nice attack on the kingside but my
media of is able to fend off the attack
and well you'll see what happens next
but before we check out the game we do
have a nice photo challenge it's gonna
be a pretty pretty tough one unless
you're from Ireland I believe so let's
check it out okay we can make it a two
fold photo challenge I'm pretty sure you
all know the Grandmaster on on the left
and feed a president election is so feel
free to tell to try and guess who the
person on the left is but the real
question is who is the person on the
right I will give you a little hint he
has been writing a chess column for the
Irish Times since 1955 which pretty much
makes it the longest ongoing chess
column in the world regarding chess so
there you have it if you are from
Ireland you should definitely buy this
man a beer or perhaps even dinner as he
has made a lifelong contribution to
chess so there you have it if you if no
one will guess I will put a link in the
description below with some information
about these gentlemen so feel free to
check it out
so we do have two photos from this round
there we have it navara came prepared
for this game with with a nice clean
shave Mahmoud er of rocking the beard
but a very neat one at that so let's
check out this game Madero has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 Knight to f6
c4 e6 Knight to f3 in the antonyms oh
and the d5 of course transposing into
the Queens gambit declined III we have
c5 immediately Knight to c3 a6 and now C
captures on d5 one of the few openings
the Queens gambit declined where it's
okay to break the tension in the center
for white he capture Sun d5 and now
Bishop to e2 Knight to c6 developing we
have castles seek after sandy for Knight
capture son d4 and bishop
v6 and here mama TR goes b3 as this is
the strongest move recommended by the
engine I imagine it's it's a prepared
align for mommy they are off as well as
a Navarro's reply here as you can
continue developing pieces Queen c7 but
should be seven you can even castle but
Bishop to e5 so kind of breaking an
opening principle but he wants to
exchange some pieces definitely a
prepared line Knight captures on c6 with
an attack on the Queen so we don't have
time to grab the knight and c3b captures
on c6 and now a Bishop to b2 and here we
have h5i very nice move I really enjoyed
this move because it's a move I would
most likely play and you know I would
most likely lose this game but Navarro
also plays it and it's a very tricky
move if you simply continue developing
with something like rook to c1 then you
get a classic Bishop sacrifice the h5
move is now guarding the g4 square so
the knight is able to come there so
after a bunch of captures you would lose
a clean pawn here as it's impossible to
capture back because the Knight to g4
check is coming and now after King to G
1 of course Queen to h4 threatening
checkmate on h2 you can capture the
night but then you have another problem
here also the queen is coming to h2 if
you try and block this create an escape
route for the King g3 is coming and now
there is no defense against Queen to h2
and if you've never seen NH 2 sacrifice
with the bishop it doesn't matter
for example after night the g4 check you
can even come to h3 but then this is a
double check from the bishop and the
night you lose the Queen here and it
doesn't help if you come to g2 reader
because then h4 is coming forcing you to
h3 to lose the Queen once again or if
you come to a 4 then Queen to f6 will be
checkmate so a very interesting idea h5
of course my media will not fall for
this he pushes f4 first fans of the
Bishop from e5 we have Bishop back to b8
and now Knight to a4 we have Knight
Bishop to a7 not allowing Knights to
come to c5 but also pressuring this e3
pawn as it is a weak backwards pawn
bishop to d4 we have
Bishop to g4 now and here mommy Jeff
simply captures the bishop showing that
there are no actual threats here bishop
characters on g4 h captures on g4 and
now rope to c1 even continuing
development and it seems like you know
if this Queen could ever come to h4 then
it could be a dangerous position for
white the problem is there's no where I
mean if you play something like nice to
e4 to prepare this then Queen can simply
capture on g4 and there is a no continue
no good continuation here for black and
on the other hand if you try something
like g3 it's actually perfectly fine
that capture it h capture some g3 and
now after Knight to e4
for example attacking the g3 pawn you
can simply defended rook to f3 there's
no way for you to capture both these
pawns are preventing the Queen from
entering the game it's a very nice
position for white so after Luke 2 c1
Navarro goes Queen to d6 we have Queen
to c2 now attacking the the c6 pawn and
here if you play something like rook to
CH to defend the pawn well that's not
entirely possible because your bishop is
hanging on a 7 so after something like
Bishop to d4 was played in the game he
captures on d4 and now you have to
decide what to do with your backwards c6
pawn if you defend it with rook to see
it then you get a rook to e1 this comes
with you check and have to remove the
King it seems like okay your king is
somewhat safe on f8 and perhaps you want
to use the open H semi-open H file for
the attack but white will exchange
Queens here and you will have no attack
your white will just enjoy his position
double rooks on the C file and you know
start attacking the seed the week C pawn
and D a pond so after he captures on d4
we have castles Queen captures on c6
so now our sacrifices upon but
temporarily as you'll see Queen to a3
trying to infiltrate the position and
also attacking the a to pawn Queen to c2
defending rook a to c8 attacking the
Queen and now Queen the b2 you might be
able to even capture two rooks here for
the Queen but there is no reason to do
this King h7 Knight to c3 defending the
and although white might be perfectly
fine here if you don't have to give up
the Queen don't do it you know unless
you're newsmen Dean of playing
electronic off but ok Queen to be two
now offering your Queen trade and here
we have Queen captures on b2 night
capture some b2 rope capture son c1 rock
captors and c1 and now rook to e8 so
mama tariff is up upon but as you'll see
it will not be all that easy to keep
this pawn rook to e8 by navara
threatening rook to e4 to capture either
the F pawn or the e or the D or the D
pawn but also if you try and defend it
with something like rook to g3 then look
to it e 2 will be a very active move
attacking tonight if you move the night
the a to pawn will be weak if you
defended this then your position is just
terrible both of your P your to only two
pieces are now completely passive and
after Knight to e4 you are still up a
pawn but you can't move anything no one
would enjoy playing this would white
so after rook to e8 a nice move by
Omidyar of King to f1 a king you know
it's not just a spectator in the endgame
in the game it becomes a very valuable
piece rook to e4 and now g3 given up the
d4 pawn rook captures on d4 and now came
to e2 again improving the position of
the King so the material is now equal
and g5 by navara we have F capture son
g5 and now Knight to e4 going after the
g5 pawn Knight to d3
Knight capture son g5 and now Knight to
f2 pressuring the g4 pawn rook to be 4
with ideas of perhaps pushing this pawn
or a5 a4 would also be very nice for
black rook to c5 attacking the d5 pawn
and now of course you cannot pull the d4
as your knight is hanging on g5 so first
nice to e4 defending the d5 pawn would a
tactic now of course you cannot capture
it because this check will pick up the
rook
so here rook to a5 is played by mama
dr.oz
we have nice - f2 King captures on f2
and now
rope to b6 a defending the a6 porn but
giving up the d5 pawn but as you'll see
number has a plan to win the pawn back
rook captures on d5 and now comes Rock
to h6 at
backing the h2 upon and here a very
interesting moment in the game it seems
like you can keep the extra point with
King to g1 the problem is after a move
like rook to c6 rope to a5 and now comes
King to h7 and after King to have two
trying to bring the King back into the
game
now black will just show you that this
is impossible due to rook to e6 and now
you see that the g4 pawn ended the rook
create like a tomb here for the White
King the White King is unable to enter
the game and white will not be able to
push his extra pawn advantage from
position like this so after up to h6 of
a very you know endgame class move from
Medea of King to e3 allowing Navarro to
capture the h2 pawn rook captures on h2
and now rook to a5 defending the a to
pawn and also attacking the a sect spawn
here
f5 allowing mummy dear after capture on
a6 now you see the problem if you play
rook to h6 to defend the a5 pawn then
you get rook to g5 with check and what
do you do here now of course you can
block this we drove to g6 but then this
is a completely lost you will simply
lose the g4 point here if you block this
then after rook captures pawn captures
although the material is equal it's a
winning endgame for for white due to the
these points being doubled you can
simply push here and you know two
against one on the Queen side the King
has to run on the Queen side you will
simply pick up the King set points and
then push the Jeep on the victory for
example so okay after up to a 5
we have f5 not allowing Grove g5 check
rook captures an a6 and now comes rope
the g2 attacking the g2 pawn g3 pawn
king f4 rook F to check the King g5 and
now comes Rock f3 attacking the pawn and
Nama media of simply plays came to h4
and now it is obvious that Madara will
indeed keep his ex keep his extra pawn a
King to f7 Navarre now improves the
position of asking before mama dro
starts pushing his ex he is passed pawns
that's a passed pawn I really saw how
you enjoyed that little past fast bone
skirmish in the previous video but it's
a passed pawn
came to e7 b5 now came to d7 rope to a7
check King to d6 and now rope to f7 here
what do you play
if you attack the the pawn with King to
c5 then you get a for the points we'll
take care of each other here so a troop
to f7
rook to f2 and here b6 rook to capture
son a - and now rook captures on f5 we
have looked to be - attacking the pawn
here and here a very nice move by on
there of rook to h5 capturing the g4
pawn was also possible and perhaps even
better but okay mama Darville goes for
rock to h5 here what do you play you
have to understand that capturing here
would lose it the game immediately
there's no way you have to know these
things
right away because I have to look h6
would check King moves rope capture
screen captures King captures now you
have to immediately see that you will be
able to push this bone all the way to
promotion and black will not be able to
prevent this so ok after this rook to h5
move of course you cannot capture here
we have rook to be for not allowing
whites to capture the g4 pawn we have
looked to h8 again you cannot capture on
b6 because of the same idea we have king
e5 rook to b8 and now King to f6 King to
h5 King to g7 now come scheme to g5 came
to f7 and now comes rock to b7 also
possible here was came to h6 because now
after black makes a move less a rogue b5
b7 is coming and have to look to be sex
chat you play King to g5 and now you
will be able to capture the g4 point
because if black defends it then you get
a look to h8 and now of course it's a
winning game if you capture on b7
then you're gonna lose the rook and you
cannot prevent the pawn from queening or
you will lose the rogue due to this
check here so this was also a possible
idea of course this would not happen
black would simply have to give up the
g4 pawn and then it's a winning endgame
but okay King f7 we have looked to b7
check King to e8 came to h4 came to f8
King to h5
them you know just trying something King
e8 we have looked to be a check King of
Seven Kings to g5 came to g7 rock to be
seven check King to f8 King to f6 King
create and this is the position I had in
mind when I named the video as I did
here mama D are played rook to b8 check
but there was a really really a hidden
brilliancy here so feel free to pause
the video here if you you know enjoy
you know pausing videos and try to find
the move
mama yeah and probably both navara
missed in this position it's it's really
a brilliancy there's no other way to put
it
so feel free I will get a couple of
seconds if you want to decide whether to
do it or not here the move that was
missed for those of you who were able to
do it you are a brilliant and game
player and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy the show rook to e7 check
now of course all of you thought about
look listen and check about the idea is
why rook to e7 check is so powerful you
know whenever you have a diagram or a
chess puzzle to solve it almost never
starts with a check so probably why at
2,800 plus Grandmaster didn't even
consider it or he did considered but he
didn't think much of it
the reason it immediately wins is after
King to d8 now you get b7 of course you
simply push the passed pawn and after
rook the b6 check you have this King to
f7 move and now the idea is simple
the threat is rook checks after remove
the King and then pawn promoted to a
queen a rock rooks get exchanged the
King goes over to so the g4 pawn wins it
and then you push the g3 pawn to victory
so let's say something like rook b3 is
played here comes check you move the
Queen is brought into the game captures
captures captures and now you have to
see that like in the previous position
the King is able to capture this pawn
and he will be able to ottoman over the
skin because the king is in front of the
passport that's where you should always
put your king so there you have it
and also another thing you have to see
after this King to d8 move
b7 rook checks King to f7 black can also
play rook to f6 check you have to
consider this as well because now if you
got rid it's stalemate the rook and pawn
are completely cutting off the king the
King has nowhere to go
it's stalemate but again you have to see
that after rook to f6
you can simply push the king to g7 and
now after black captures you will get
the Queen into the game or if you bring
the rook back rook to b6 to defend rook
to f7 is coming with the same idea you
will simply check bring the Queen into
the game exchange rooks win the pawn and
then win the game so okay rook to e7 the
hidden brilliancy what happens if King
comes to f8 it's also very nice if the
King comes to f8 first you play rook to
f7 check and now the king can either go
back to yet or to f8 if the King goes
back now you simply play b7 rook checks
King moves and now it's the same threat
you will simply play rock to f8 check
bring the Queen exchange rooks when the
pawn and pull the g3 point victory or if
the king after this check goes to g8
which is also a possibility of course if
King to g8 then you get rock to b7
a very nice idea after black plays a
move there aren't all that many moves
here and now comes King to g6
threatening checkmate with rook to b8
King f8 and now after the King has moved
and now you check the king after the
King moves this is the only square for
the King now you get b7 King moves and
the now comes rock to h8 and now again a
winning position if you exchange then
look to h7 wins the rock exchanges the
rook and then King wins the g4 opponent
pushes the g3 point to victory or if you
don't capture it if you bring the King
closer it doesn't really matter you will
simply Queen the pawn captures captures
captures and then win the g4 pawn and
push the g3 point to victory so a very
nice idea I mean it's a it's a position
that could very well happen in one of
your own games so you know you should
may perhaps remember this if there are
two points you have a pawn here you know
not not impossible rook to e7 check wins
the game but okay rook to b8 check was
played
the game we have King 37 and now came to
g5 King to c6 and now comes King to h4 v
rook to e4 rook the g8 attacking the g4
pawn king captures rook captures of
course you cannot exchange rooks rope to
e3 and now rook to g7 King c6g for Mama
Yara starts pushing his passed pawn
Kings e6 we have g5 kinky sex King to g6
we have rope to g3 and after rook to a7
this is move 68 and it was in this
position that David navara resigned the
game why did you resign because it's a
well known winning position for the side
that has the extra pawn for example
after black makes a move rook to a3 for
example cutting off the king from the
h-file the king is cutting off the key
the white hint from the F file you can
simply move after Luke g3 you put the
pawn after Luke h3 you can simply check
the King King moves now you move the
King again after you pin the pawn check
you move the King who have check King
moves now comes upon comes to g7 and now
how do you promote the pawn after black
makes a move you check the King King
moves you play rook a to after black
makes a move you play rook e to after
black makes any move now you go rook to
e4 a very important move you should
remember this one as now whatever black
plays you of course make the room for
the pawn and after black starts checking
you with the rook now you play rock here
King here rock G to Richard King of six
now you got away rook to f3 checking the
king now King comes to g5 and after
check you will block the check and the
now you can freely put a queen the g7
pawn captures captures and there is no
stopping from from queening this pawn
so after Luke to a7 and Navarre I didn't
play this out as it's a well known win
and a very nice victory for sha here
mommy er off and I did prepare the
standings after round 7 so here they are
as you can see my Madeira is now a full
point ahead of Magnus Carlsen and Peter
Svidler cousin with four and a half's
wheeler wood for then Maxima
three and a half and Davi Navarro with
three and the nicocure God is still with
only half a point out of seven but as
you all know those that half a point
came from Magnus Carlsen so yeah
cousin mama D are also a madero already
faced Nico twice so he defeated an eco
two times cross and when we played
against him once so there he will have
his chance to create a full point
against Nico but you know it will
probably be a lot of pressure for him
you know as he is the only one who was
unable to defeat him and if he will not
defeat him in in the next next time they
play it will be very unlikely that he
will be able to catch up to mama DRF but
today I believe today calls and faces no
today costs and faces fiddler and also
gonna be a very important match if you
know that could decide to the fate of
this tournament so yeah that's the game
a wonderful end game a wonderful game
all in all a wonderful mist brilliancy
so there you have it I do hope you
enjoyed it and that you're enjoying the
coverage of the bill series I believe I
don't I have no idea how long this video
is might be a bit longer sorry about
that but you know it's an end game what
can you do I would like to thank Doug in
Gaul a sly and the Michael Carr for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon with a couple of more rounds
from the bill chess festival if there
will be some interesting games today and
or of course continuing the Bobby
Fischer series thank you all and I'll
see you soon